poursuivant cette chronique échos du
jeudi et économie et rime aussi avec
bande dessinée alors eh oui aujourd'hui
oui avec ce chef d'entreprise yvelinois
dans la société a connu des déboires et
qu'il a consignées dans un livre c'était
il ya deux ans il a version bd vient de
sortir on écoute ses explications
l'histoire de seul hic ces dix années de
croissance ininterrompue
ces dix années de bénéfices c'est j'ai
recruté mon premier salarié au 92e
et puis un jour vous avez la faillite de
lehman brothers le 15 septembre 2008 et
qui nous précipite effectivement dans
des difficultés financières et en moins
de neuf mois j'ai perdu un peu plus de
deux millions sept cent mille euros
j'ai dû restructurer toute l'entreprise
j'ai dû licencier les deux tiers de mes
collaborateurs déposé le bilan après
avoir déposé le bilan mon entreprise
lorsque je suis sortie du tribunal de
commerce de nanterre ce que je t'ai
miraculé dans le 92
j'ai souhaité
un peu faire ma thérapie est en gros je
me suis dit j'ai deux options soit je
perds deux en faire une thérapie auprès
d'un psychiatre soit j'ai décidé d'en
écrire un bouquin est en fait mon choix
s'est tourné naturellement vers vernoux
rage et cette nouvelle bd qui vient tout
juste de sortir a pour mérite en fait de
faire un peu de pédagogie
ce qui a tout un lexique à la fin on
explique qu est ce que le redressement
judiciaire qu'est ce que la gouvernance
d'entreprise
qu'est ce que la crise comment licencié
comment orchestrer ça se veut aussi est
un petit peu un guide pratique aux
pratiques pour tout chef d'entreprise
dirigeants ou salariés qui aimerait voir
un petit peu justement comment comment
on est amené à gérer une entreprise
toutes les recettes à juste titre monte
intégralement dans mon entreprise donc
seul hic et a pour vocation puisque je
sais c'est de faire bénéficier de cette
image au même titre que les animations
les conférences que je peux faire à
travers la france ont pour objectif de
contribuer à rembourser la dette parce
que même si on a validé un plan de
continuation
d'abord il ya un remboursement sur dix
ans la dette d'origine était 2 millions
400 mille euros et à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui me reste encore un million
de à rembourser